>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Harrison Smith: Good morning.
>> Good morning.
>> Harrison Smith: Lovely
to see everyone today.
My name is Harrison
Smith, and I am a reporter
with the Kids Post section
of The Washington Post.
And it is my great honor today
to introduce Ali Benjamin, who,
as we all know, is the
best-selling author
of "The Thing About Jellyfish."
"The Thing About Jellyfish" won
a national book award, excuse me,
was a National Book Award
finalist just last year.
And it tells the story of a
12-year-old girl, Suzy Swanson,
who believes that her
friend, Franny,
died not because of a swimming
accident, but because of a sting
of a rare jellyfish, a teeny, tiny,
many-tentacled animal
called the Irukandji.
"The Thing About Jellyfish"
is a book,
not just about venomous jellies,
of course, but about grief
and friendship, and even
the scientific method.
It delves into the nature of
extinction, and the awareness
of a funny thing called
zombie ants, which,
as one of the characters explains,
are ants whose brains have been
taken over by a funny fungus.
In a review for The New York Times,
the writer Jacqueline Kelly
praised Ali's "dreamy,
meditative and elegiac prose."
And it's a style of writing
that she honed over the years,
working primarily as
a non-fiction writer.
She's the co-author of a pair
of memoirs, "The Keeper,"
about U.S. soccer goalie
Tim Howard, and "Positive,"
about a middle-schooler's
struggles with HIV.
With Beth Bader, she also
wrote "The Cleaner Plate Club,"
a recipe book designed
to help parents feed kids
something a little healthier
than potato chips or PB & Js.
And in 2011, one year after
the release of that book,
Ali also worked on television,
as the story researcher
and casting director for
"Growing Hope Against Hunger,"
an hour-long Sesame Street
special about child hunger,
and that won an Emmy award
for outstanding children's
non-fiction program.
There will be time for questions
after the talk, fortunately,
and I should add that anyone who
has a question will be filmed
for The Library of
Congress' archives.
Ali is also going to be signing
books today from noon to 1 pm.
Before we start, I want to thank
the Festival's co-chairman,
David Rubinstein, and the many
National Book Festival sponsors
who made this event
possible in 2016.
The Washington Post is a
charter sponsor of the Festival,
and The Library of
Congress has been its host
since the Book Fest
began 16 years ago.
If you'd like, you, too, can
support the Festival whether
through making a donation,
there's some information about that
in your programs, or
by joining me now
in welcoming Ali Benjamin
at the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> Ali Benjamin: Hi, guys.
Oh, that's not going to work.
How's everybody doing?
Good? Great.
So I'm going to be talking a
little bit about the book today,
but I'm actually going to be talking
more about the theme of curiosity.
Somebody recently asked me to sum
up this book in a single word.
And that is the word, curiosity.
It begins with -- wait, where
is my Bluetooth clicker?
Sorry. Here we go.
The story of the book
begins with this kid.
This is my younger daughter, who,
from the time she was an infant,
was crazy about sea life and fish.
And we live in rural Massachusetts,
we're surrounded by farms.
There's no ocean nearby.
But if we walked into a Petco
and there were some fish swimming
in a fish tank, she would start
quivering with excitement.
I, myself, never thought
that much about the sea.
I would go to the beach
sometimes, but what do you see
when you go to the beach?
You look at the water, and you
see the surface of the water.
You don't see what's underneath.
And I never really spent
very much time wondering
about what was underneath.
I never thought about jellyfish
other than if I saw one
in the water, I would get
right out of the water.
But she was really curious, and
she wanted to read as many books
about sea life as she could.
So one day, she had a
day off from school,
and I have an older daughter, too.
They're very, very different,
and I was trying to think,
what can I do that both girls
are going to want to do?
And we went into Boston,
and we went to the aquarium.
And it was a very loud
day at the aquarium.
It was -- there were a lot
of school groups there.
It was very, very crowded, and it
was really, like, it was great,
but at a certain point, I
wanted some peace and quiet.
And so we sought out the quietest
room in the place, which happened
to be the jellyfish exhibit.
And I really went there only
looking for some peace and quiet.
But while I was there, I was
looking at these creatures
that were behind glass and
they're sort of moving,
and I thought they look kind of
like space aliens, and they're kind
of pulsing, and I was
thinking holy cow,
like the ocean is filled with these.
We're occupying the same earth,
we're occupying the same space,
and I don't know anything
about them.
I don't know how they eat,
I don't know what they eat,
and so I started wondering.
I'm just going to take a few
minutes to talk about curiosity.
Albert Einstein said that he was
never particularly clever or gifted.
All he was was really curious.
Walt Disney said something
very similar,
that curiosity leads
us down new paths.
Eleanor Roosevelt said that if a
fairy godmother could endow a child
with one gift at birth, that
gift should be curiosity.
I could go on and on and on
with slides about curiosity.
This is me with my nephew.
He is a toddler.
I see that there are a lot
of parents in the audience.
What do toddlers do a lot of?
They do a lot of asking
questions, right?
There's actually a researcher who
has gone into homes with toddlers
and investigated how many
questions toddlers ask
that are actively seeking
information about the world.
Why is it this way?
And she said, on average,
it's like 100 questions a day.
Now sometimes when I go into
school groups, I'll ask the kids
to do some quick calculations.
100 questions a day, 365 days a
year, over the course of two years,
anybody know off-hand
how many -- any kids?
Can you say how many questions?
You're nodding.
How many questions would that
be over the course of two years?
73,000, but yeah, it's
a lot of questions.
Which is why, when you see parents
of toddlers, they are often, like,
oh, my goodness, I just
need some peace and quiet.
But something interesting
happens over time.
This is a chart that I won't
go into in too much detail,
but that yellow line there is the
number of questions that kids ask
that are actively seeking
information about the world,
because that same researcher
who went into the homes
of toddlers also went
into school classrooms.
And you notice that the questions
sort of rise dramatically,
and then they start tapering off,
to the point where when they are 18,
it's a fraction of what they were.
And she actually went
into classrooms
and evaluated how many
information-seeking questions kids
tended to ask over the
average hour in a classroom.
And are there any guesses
about how many that would be?
One hour. How many
questions in a classroom?
>> Two.
>> Ali Benjamin: Two?
>> Eight.
>> Ali Benjamin: Eight?
Anyone else?
Guys, the answer is zero.
In the average classroom, there
are questions being asked,
but they tend to be questions like
"is this going to be on the test?"
Which is not the kind of
questions that we're talking about.
So sometimes I ask kids
to give me their theories
about why that might be.
What's their hypotheses about
why do we stop asking questions
as we get older?
And by the way, that's a
fifth and six grade classroom.
Any kids have any theories
about why?
And I don't have the answer.
I'll just say I don't
have the answer.
All right.
I'll tell you what
answers I often get.
Kids will say to me, "Well, we
can look things up ourselves."
And I think that is a great
response, because that's true.
And they say, "Well, we know more."
Except then often another kid points
out that every question you
get an answer to actually opens
up more questions, so
theoretically, the more you know,
the more you're actually
going to ask.
And I can tell you, I have
talked to school groups all
over the country at this point.
In every single classroom, there
is a kid who raises their hand
who says, "Because
you're embarrassed."
Because you're embarrassed to ask a
question, because asking a question,
what you're curious about, reveals
something about yourself that starts
to make you feel exposed.
And I don't think it's a coincidence
that the questions really start
going down when kids become aware
of themselves as an entity that
other people might be looking
at when they have that
self-awareness.
I became curious about jellyfish.
I started asking questions.
And all I was seeking at the
beginning was to learn more.
I went to the gift shop at the
aquarium that day and I looked
for a book about jellyfish.
I couldn't find one.
We went to a bookstore
that afternoon.
I went to the science section,
to the non-fiction section,
to the kids section.
I couldn't find any books about it.
I went home.
I went onto Amazon thinking
surely they've got something.
And I couldn't find anything.
I couldn't find anything that
had really good concrete value.
But I started reading these magazine
articles from science magazines
and New York Times
articles, and I was like,
"This is really interesting stuff."
We're going to play a true
or false game right now.
True or false?
Jellyfish are older than dinosaurs?
>> True.
>> Ali Benjamin: True.
They are older.
Not only than dinosaurs,
they're older than trees,
they're older than seeds,
they're older than bony fish.
They are older than just about
any animal that you can think
of that you have ever seen.
Not single-celled life.
They are at least 500 million
years old, and you can basically,
they are in more or less the same
form they were when they originated.
All right.
True or false?
Jellyfish sting with the
pressure of a bullet?
>> True.
>> Ali Benjamin: It's true.
So they've got these tiny -- I'm not
going to go into too much details,
here, but you sort of see
these three yellow things?
They are stinger cells, and
they've got millions and millions
and millions of stinger cells.
And what happens is they
brush against something,
and in a split second, far faster
than it takes for our brain to sort
of make our bodies
react to something hot,
in a fraction of a second,
they've got these stinger things
that are coiled like harpoons, and
it releases out and it releases
with the pressure of a
bullet, millions of them.
And that is why it hurts so badly.
True or false?
You guys, I'm sure know
the answer to this.
Jellyfish have brains.
>> False.
>> Ali Benjamin: False.
They have no brains, no
bones, no blood, no heart.
None of the things that I
always thought of as the things
that animal have --
that animals have.
By the way, this was once
considered as a title
for "The Thing About Jellyfish."
And then I was told no, it
really shouldn't be that,
because everybody's going to
think it's a book about zombies.
True or false?
Jellyfish are starving other
creatures in the ocean?
>> True.
>> Ali Benjamin: Yeah,
it's true, actually.
They are, with the warming of
the oceans, and the acidification
of the oceans, I'm sure, kids,
you guys probably talk some
about climate change in
your science classes.
That's real.
So jellyfish seasons are now --
they like a warm ocean,
for the most part.
Their seasons are much longer
now than they used to be.
And they are starting
to take the food.
And so they're rising in numbers.
As they're rising in numbers,
they're taking the food
that traditionally
went to other animals.
And they're also eating
the eggs of other fish
that would otherwise have a
chance to rise in numbers.
They're rising in such numbers,
the numbers are swelling so fast
that there are scientists
out there who believe
that jellyfish will one day
starve whales to extinction,
and penguins to extinction.
That is an actual thing that
people are talking about.
It's a terrifying fact.
It's absolutely terrifying.
Jellyfish blooms causing serious
damage to earth's ecosystem.
That is a jellyfish
bloom right there.
True or false?
You guys probably know
the answer to this.
The bigger the jellyfish,
the more dangerous it is?
>> False.
>> Ali Benjamin: Yeah,
totally false.
So that's a lion's mane jellyfish.
It can grow up to eight feet across
the bell, that sort of round part.
They have found ones with tentacles
as long as 100 feet that have washed
up on shore, which is
crazy to think about.
Though I often, with kids,
will show this next slide
and say don't believe everything
you see on the internet.
That is a photoshopped picture.
That's real.
That's false.
So size has nothing to do with it.
It really has to do with
what the venom is inside.
And that, right there, is
the Irukandji jellyfish.
If you look at it, it is
transparent, it lives --
it's only been found off
the shores of Australia.
It causes something
called Irukandji Syndrome,
that in the best case scenario,
causes your blood pressure to rise,
causes excruciating
pain, excruciating pain,
so much that patients, people who
have it, not only are convinced
that they're going to die,
sometimes they beg doctors
to just get it over with sooner.
It can cause the brain
to hemorrhage.
It is not as fatal as the box
jellyfish, which is its cousin,
but it's still pretty
darned dangerous.
If you notice, it can -- it's
sort of the size of a thumbnail,
and it's totally transparent.
Would you ever see
that in the water?
No. You never would.
True or false?
Jellyfish can grow younger?
Mixed things here.
Guys, there is a species
of jellyfish,
they have dubbed it The Immortal
Jellyfish, that when it is stressed,
when there are stressful
conditions in the ecosystem,
it can reverse its lifecycle.
They have the -- just real
short, they have this life cycle
where you get a fertilized
egg in the water,
it goes down to the
bottom of the ocean,
it grows as what's called a polyp
tethered to the bottom of the sea.
At a certain point, when
conditions are right,
it releases from the
bottom of the sea,
and it grows up into what we
think of as the adult jellyfish.
When that adult jellyfish
is stressed, it can go back
to being a polyp at
the bottom of the sea.
That is like if I could
suddenly go back --
I find this situation standing
in front of all of you very,
very stressful, so suddenly you have
me as a toddler, my nephew's age,
standing in front of you trying
to deliver this presentation.
It really is like that.
It's outstanding.
It's the only creature
we know that can do it.
Look it up.
The New York Times
has done articles.
The Immortal Jellyfish.
So here, we've got this creature.
It looks like aliens.
They're mindless like zombies.
You can trace the history of
life on earth through jellyfish.
They're dangerous as heck.
They're at the forefront
of our changing planet.
And they hold the secret
to immortality.
And I couldn't find a
single book about jellyfish.
So Toni Morrison -- kids, I hope
someday you read Toni Morrison,
not yet, but some day -- once said,
"If there's a book you really want
to read, but it hasn't been written
yet, then you must write it."
I remember sitting there
reading these articles
and thinking why isn't there a book?
And thinking what if I have to
write a book about jellyfish?
And I remember I went
to my mother-in-law's.
I had just finished somebody
else's memoir, and she said,
"What is your next book
going to be about?"
And I scratched my head and I said,
"I think it's going to
be about jellyfish."
And she laughed, which, it was okay,
because it did seem really absurd.
I have done a lot of science
writing, but I'm not a scientist,
and I thought who the heck am I
to write a book about jellyfish?
But I started writing.
And here we have this book,
"The Thing About Jellyfish."
It came out last year.
I'm going to very quickly
go through the story.
I'm not going to talk
a lot about it.
But the basic plot is there's a
12-year-old girl, Suzy Swanson,
whose best friend has just
drowned while on summer vacation.
Suzy -- Franny, her friend,
was a very, very good swimmer,
and it really confuses her.
She's also at the age where, and
this is very much what I remember
about being that age,
where you suddenly realize
that not every story
gets a happy ending.
And sometimes really bad
things happen, and it stinks
and somehow you have
to learn with it.
And I remember I had this cognitive
dissonance when I was that age
and I was thinking,
like, how can that be?
Somebody's got to make this right.
It can't just end like this.
So she, in her grief, and I should
say that their friendship had broken
up in a very dramatic way before her
friend passed away, and she has not
yet had a chance to make it right.
And then she finds out
that her friend died,
and she is just absolutely
wrecked with guilt and with grief.
And she stops speaking.
She doesn't talk to
anyone in her life,
not her parents, not her teachers.
This is sort of, almost
like an internal protest
to the world being this way.
And one day she goes to the aquarium
on a school trip and she wanders,
she goes looking for
the quietest room
in the aquarium while she's there,
and it's the jellyfish exhibit.
The story of how the book begins
is actually the same story --
or is actually the same story
that unfolds as the book begins.
And she looks at these jellyfish,
and she reads about the Irukandji
jellyfish, and she decides
that actually her friend was
killed by an Irukandji jellyfish,
which are maybe starting to
migrate around the world.
And she is going to prove it.
She is going to do whatever
it takes to prove it.
And she decides she's going
to enlist help from people.
There are real -- there's a
lot of non-fiction that's woven
into this book, and one
of the non-fiction parts is she
begins researching people who know
about jellyfish, people
who have experience
with jellyfish who
maybe can help her.
The one on the left is Diana Nyad.
You guys know who Diana
Nyad is, right?
Sometimes kids don't
know who Diana Nyad is.
She tried for many decades, five
times, to swim from Cuba to Florida,
and a number of those
times had to stop
because she was stung
so badly by jellyfish.
The jellyfish in the middle is a
recently-discovered jellyfish by --
it was discovered by a
scientist/haiku poet.
It's called the Paper Lantern
Jellyfish, because it can sort
of crumple up and it sort of
looks almost like a paper lantern.
And then the guy on the
right is named Jamie Seymour.
He is a toxicologist.
He works in Australia.
That's him holding an
Irukandji jellyfish.
He is the world's foremost
researcher of Irukandji jellyfish.
And she looks at him and
she's like, that's the guy.
That's the guy who's
going to help me out.
But he's in Australia.
She's all the way in Massachusetts.
So a big question in this book,
sort of the heart of the book,
is how far will she go
to make things right on
behalf of her friend?
Along the way she discovers
some pretty startling things.
One is that each of us, everybody,
all of you sitting out there,
you've got at least 60,000
miles of blood vessels going
through your body, which is enough,
if you line them up end to end,
to circle the world
two and a half times.
Like, that's in you right now.
Every one of you sitting out there
probably has at least two billion
of Shakespeare's atoms, atoms
that were once inside William
Shakespeare, inside of you.
I will say, when you write a book
that has a lot of non-fiction,
there's a lot of fact
checking that goes on.
This was one that there was
a lot of discussion about.
Other people have said
200 billion atoms.
We did some really interesting
calculations to say, like, okay,
but he lived on another continent
and we -- I mean, it was --
we sort of worked to figure
out what the right number --
that's probably a conservative
estimate.
And then the very simple
fact that all of us,
everything in you right
now is crafted from stars
that existed at the dawn of time.
Which I -- when I think about that,
it is a really mind-blowing fact.
This is one of the things
she discovers as she's sort
of doing her research and trying
to make science work for her.
She understands, she begins to
understand that science isn't
about formulas from a textbook.
Science is about a
world that's around us
that is actually astonishing.
So, I'm writing this book
that part of me feels
like I have no business to write.
I don't know at the beginning if
I'm writing fiction or non-fiction.
Now it's easy for me to
tell you what the story is.
I have to tell you when I
started writing about jellyfish,
I thought I was writing
a non-fiction book.
But I didn't -- yeah, fiction,
non-fiction, I did not,
as I was writing, anytime I
tried to write only non-fiction,
it did not capture the wonder that
I felt when I really looked at it.
It didn't capture what
I felt was astonishing.
It didn't feel, for me, on
paper the way I felt inside
when I thought about writing it.
So after a while, I remembered,
like, having this moment
where I was like, I think
it's a fictional book
where I can explore these
through a character.
I also didn't know if I
was writing for adults,
or if I was writing for kids.
It's a 12-year-old main character.
Some of the themes are pretty dark.
I went back and forth, and then
finally I sent it off to my agent,
and she was like, "You
are writing for kids.
Finish this."
But it was a lot -- it was very --
I just didn't know what I was doing.
I was feeling my way through
right from the beginning.
I wrote a million, I
mean, probably 14 drafts.
Ernest Hemingway said the first
draft of anything is crud.
The word he used was not crud.
I can't say the word that he used.
But he's right.
Kids, when you're in school, do
you ever have to write something
for your teachers where they
look at it, you turn it in,
your teacher looks at it, grades
it, and then hands it back to you
and says, okay, do another draft.
Yeah. And do you love it
when the teacher does that?
No! And neither did I.
But I have to say, there's a
reason that your teacher does that,
and that's because someday
you are going to want
to say something to the world.
I don't know what it is.
My guess is it's probably not
going to be about jellyfish,
but it's going to be something.
I don't know any adult who doesn't
feel something really deeply
and personally and they want
to represent it to the world.
And you often don't get
it right the first time,
or the second time,
or the third time.
And the reason your
teacher makes you do that,
is because they want you to be
in a habit, when you are ready
to take your message to the
world, to really know yourself
when it's right or
when it's not right.
I probably -- I did a number of
drafts before we even showed it
to publishers, and then we went
through several more
drafts afterwards.
And -- this is interesting
-- at a certain point,
they take the book away from you.
I don't know that I ever
felt like it was done,
but it had to go to press.
So people ask me, like, how
did you know when it was done,
and the answer is I didn't.
I just no longer had a
chance to work on it.
And it was actually for
months after it went to press,
I would be like at the
gym, and I would be running
and I would think of, like,
just the perfect line that one
of the characters could
say at a perfect moment,
and I'd be like, "That's so good!"
and I don't know what
to do with it anymore.
That was interesting,
but it was worth it.
It was a National Book
Award finalist last year.
I usually show this with a slide
contrasted to me when I was a child,
because when I was a child, I was
this really, kind of, weird --
I had these hippie, hippie parents.
I had, you know, just crazy, messy
braids, and these dirty shirts,
and food smeared all over my face,
and I think about who I was then,
and I think about kids who
are out there who maybe feel
like they don't fit in,
and I want to be like, no,
no, no, I was such a mess.
It all began with curiosity.
A nuclear physicist said those
who do not stop asking silly
questions become scientists.
I want to go back to that theme
of curiosity, and asking questions
and not being embarrassed
to ask questions.
I would just add -- or
they become writers.
And kids, if you ever do feel
self-conscious about things
that you're interested
in, maybe you feel weird
because you're the only one who's
interested in it, and it's kind of,
like, it doesn't feel right.
What I would say is just trust
it, and if you move to that thing
that you're interested in, and
then from there you're going
to see something else that you're
interested in, and then from there,
you're going to see something else.
What you will find over time,
and you can't see it yet from
where you are, is that
it becomes a life path.
And the reason you're
interested in these things
and nobody else is interested in
them, is because it's your path,
and it's not supposed
to be their path.
So we've got about five minutes.
I'm happy to take questions on
the writing process, on jellyfish,
on anything at all, really.
Yeah?
Has anyone I ever know -- has
anyone I've ever known been stung
by a jellyfish?
Yes, and I often will ask
people, and I'll ask this group.
Does anybody here know anybody
who's been stung by a jellyfish?
Yeah. Has anybody here
been stung by a jellyfish?
There are a lot of hands.
Guys, there are 150 million stings
that we know about
every single year.
That adds up to 23 every five
seconds, which means that just
since I've been talking,
it's thousands
and thousands and thousands
of stings.
Yeah?
>> In your research on
jellyfish, did you --
I remember you saying that they
are having a massive impact
on ecosystems.
>> Ali Benjamin: Yeah.
>> Did you find any, like, I guess
like natural, like a push-back
against that sheer number?
Like are they reaching a
carrying capacity that, you know,
they just eat too much food that
some die off, or is it just --
are they different to other species.
>> Ali Benjamin: That's a
good -- that's a very good --
the question is did
I find any push-back,
like where the system is
sort of righting itself.
Is that what you mean?
Like the ecosystem is sort of
finding ways of righting itself?
I did not.
I don't know that that's
not happening,
but that's not something
I've seen talked about.
And it's also worth saying at this
point there is actually now --
there wasn't when I
started writing this --
a really great adult
non-fiction book called "Stung."
It's by Lisa Ann Gershwin.
She's a scientist.
It's sort of the book
that I was, like, "Well,
I don't have any business
writing that book."
She wrote it.
It's fantastic, and
that's a very good place
to go for more information.
Yeah?
So that's a similar question.
Do jellyfish have any
natural enemies?
Yes, I mean, there are
creatures who eat them.
Sea turtles eat them, and there's
a lot of talk about all the plastic
in the oceans, and it's
because a plastic bag when it's
in the ocean can look, the way
it moves, a lot like a jellyfish,
and so there are all
these horrible stories
of sea turtles swallowing
plastic bags.
The plastic in the ocean
issue is a really huge --
I touch upon it a little
in the book.
But I don't know that it's
slowing the population down.
I don't know that's it's
not, but that's not something
that I've seen written
about recently.
Yeah?
>> Have you ever been
stung by a jellyfish?
>> Ali Benjamin: Have I ever
been stung by a jellyfish?
No, I -- stung is a strong word.
So there was that picture
of me holding jellyfish.
I want to say, if you
don't know what kind
of jellyfish you're dealing
with, don't pick them up.
There's one that I had
picked up that I --
it made my hand a little numb, but
I didn't consider that a real sting.
No, I'm a big baby, and I am a giant
frady cat, and when I see jellyfish,
I kind of run away if I
don't know what kind it is.
Yeah?
>> [inaudible] characters?
>> Ali Benjamin: Oh, how did
I come up with the characters?
That's such a good question.
I would say characters are a little
bit like people emerging from fog,
and at the beginning, all you see
is this vague outline of them,
and then the more you write, the
more it's like they're moving to you
from the fog, and you get
to see specific features.
Yeah. And they just kind of, over
time, they just kind of come.
Yeah.
>> What are you working on now?
>> Ali Benjamin: What
am I working on now?
That is a really great question.
I am working on another novel that
weaves in exploration and violence
in our society, but
it's a book for kids.
And so I've been working really
hard on trying to get the notion
of sort of, I'm particularly
interested in polar explorers,
and sort of violence, and what
are our aspirations as a species
versus where do we go small and
where does fear start to control us.
Yeah.
>> As a middle school librarian, the
guidance counselors often come to me
when we have students
that have issues
through book therapy
and book bibliotherapy.
>> Ali Benjamin: Yeah.
>> Your book is often
recommended now,
with working with middle
schoolers, that dissonance
of feeling no right and
wrong at this point.
They're still working on learning
what gray in their lives mean.
That your book is what's often
recommended to help students process
through that, so thank you.
>> Ali Benjamin: Thank you.
Thank you.
Yeah?
>> Hi. We have a joke
for you about jellyfish.
>> Ali Benjamin: Can
you all hear that?
That they have a joke
about jellyfish?
>> Yeah. What do jellyfish
get stressed about?
>> Ali Benjamin: What do
jellyfish get stressed about?
I don't know.
>> The current events.
>> Ali Benjamin: The current events!
[ Applause ]
Oh, okay, and she's waving a sign
that says wrap up,
over allotted time.
I will be here for a few minutes
if anybody wants to ask me.
Yeah.
>> I just have a question
about children and grief,
and I'd like to know what you
learned about children and grief.
Oh, okay, I'll end on this,
and then we'll go outside.
Children and grief.
What did I learn about
children and grief?
I'm often asked for answers
about children and grief,
and how children should
process grief and I --
my answer is always I don't know.
Because I feel like children are
struggling with the very same things
that we adults are struggling
with, like how could this happen,
this isn't fair, this
isn't what I wanted,
particularly when something happens
to somebody who was good or young.
And I feel like this book, in some
ways, was my own way of wrestling
with it, and saying I don't know,
all I know is eventually you go on.
I mean, it's such a
useless answer in some ways,
but it's the most honest
answer I can give to anyone.
And I'm getting -- I'm not going to
call them evil eye, but I would love
to hear your questions,
but I think they need
to set up for the next speaker.
Okay, thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.